un garage un peu particulier en région
parisienne c'est la première fois que
corinne viens ici c'est un garage
solidaire
il y en a une trentaine en france bon
alors vous venez donc pour votre vie
d'ange avec le support moteur c'est ça
sur la renault 19
on a estimé que la location elle était à
peu près de deux heures en fait corinne
loup le pont et tout le matériel qui va
avec pour effectuer les réparations car
c'est elle qui va jouer les mécanos
bravo amine casse à outils à dispo alors
d'accord avec tous les tournevis les
pinces et c'est tony le patron du garage
est là pour la guider pour la première
fois de sa vie elle va faire la vidange
de sa voiture donc là ce qu'on fait
généralement quand on fait une vidange
sais pas si vous savez mais on enlève le
bouchon pour ça coule mieux en dessous
corinne ne fais pas ça pour le plaisir
mais pour économiser beaucoup d'argent
si on prend une heure de main d'oeuvre
chez un constructeur qui est d'à peu
près 90 euros en prend en faisant la
même intervention chez nous en une heure
ça coûte 12 euros
comme elle ne paye pas la main d'oeuvre
ça ne lui coûte que la location de la
machine après la vidange corinne
s'attaque aux plaquettes de frein on va
braquer les routes et vous tourner la
roue à léser les neiges ya ici voilà
j'aurais pu aller faire autre chose me
faire
j'ai pas mon faire une manucure ou
plutôt que je me la faire après tout
seul donc c'est vrai que oui j'aurais pu
aller faire autre chose pour moi et pas
forcément pour ma voiture
maintenant vu le tarif élevé des
garagistes
je préfère me faire tout seul ça lui a
pris deux heures mais corinne a réussi à
diviser par trois sa facture et tant pis
pour la french manucure 7 milliards
d'euros c'est ce que les français
dépensent chaque année pour réparer leur
voiture près de la moitié de cette somme
ne servirait qu'à acheter les pièces
détachées mécanique ou carrosserie la
facture est souvent salée les
réparations c'est trop cher
je referme rameurs voiture au garage du
coin je sais que ma ligne mais
aujourd'hui il existe de nouveaux moyens
pour alléger sa facture casse auto
discount magasin de pièces détachées
neuves à prix cassés que valent ces
nouveaux services sont ils tous les
goûts combien ça coûte l'hebdo a mis les
mains dans le cambouis pour vous aider à
faire des économies
nous sommes dans l'une des cinq plus
grosses casse automobile de france et
ici en ce moment les parkings affichent
complet c'est la conséquence de la prime
à la casse
quatre cent mille français se sont
séparés de leurs vieilles voitures et
philippe le patron se retrouve avec tout
un stock sur les bras
c'est des véhicules en très bon état
jamais vu autre chose que des housses
le problème c'est que le prix de l'acier
s'est effondré en un an il est passé de
300 euros la tonne à 70 euros
du coup ces véhicules qu'il revend
ferrailleur pour recycler l'acier ne lui
rapporte plus grand chose
alors pour rentabiliser au maximum
philippe a une idée
tous les deux mois il organise des
soldes un peu particulier mon idée c'est
justement faire cette case discount et
met à disposition de personnes de
véhicules comme ça pour un prix défiant
toute concurrence
c'est à dire qu'on va vendre sa au kilo
est à 2 euros 50 le kilo c'est comme une
promotion dans un hypermarché
ce matin ils sont une dizaine d'amateurs
ils doivent réparer leur voiture mais
leur budget serré ils sont tous venus
avec leur casse à outils et même leur
liste de courses parce qu'ils vont
devoir tout démonter tout seul
plage arrière tapis de coffre
clignotants avant gauche aux priorités
id roissy si son beau d'été genre clio
temps je me souviens serait 205 et d'en
racheter un neuf films a coûté 20 euro
venait là ça fait 150 g de 52 kg il n'y
a pas photo
des voitures françaises des grosses
berlines étrangères des monospaces très
recherchés il y en a pour tous les goûts
il suffit de ne pas se tromper dans le
modèle est de ne pas avoir peur de se
salir bien sûr par flambant neufs
injecteurs en très bon état et même des
étriers qui peuvent servir encore des
années et de détruire à saïda pour 600
euros à deux ça ça vaut jusqu'à 500
euros pièce et au moment de passer sur
la balance philippe fait forcément des
heureux j'étais à 4 août gaulle une aile
de gaulle ou face avant du golfe
radiateur de golf de zèle normalement la
vous en avez pour 60 ans je suis pas 3,4
cela va être une remise de 90 % par
rapport au prix tout ça pour moins de 40
euros
ces voitures destinées à être détruites
philippe les achète 200 euros environ
d'habitude ce sont ces employés qui font
tout ce travail de récup une voiture au
final ça lui revient très cher
d'où son idée de faire faire le travail
par ses clients demandeurs de démontage
c'est à charge de l'acheteur c'est ce
qui fait toute la différence est ce qui
nous permet de vendre une des pièces à
des prix vraiment discours je peux
l'abbé pierre lachat le businessman ce
samedi va rapporter dix mille euros à
notre business man sans rien faire bien
sûr ce ne sont que des pièces d'occasion
et il n'y a pas de garantie mais c'est
surtout quand on veut acheter des pièces
neuves que ça se complique
en france pour tout ce qui est pièces
détachées mécanique la concurrence
marche à plein régime grâce à internet
on peut même trouver des essuie glaces à
moitié prix
des courroies de distribution à -40% ou
encore des plaquettes de frein 60% moins
cher mais si on doit changer une pièce
de carrosserie une portière ou un simple
pare-chocs et qu'on possède une voiture
de marque française
il n'y a pas le choix les constructeurs
automobiles français ont le monopole un
des derniers cas en europe et malgré la
volonté de bruxelles la france n'a
toujours pas ouvert ce marché de la
carrosserie à la concurrence
du coup il faut payer le prix fort comme
le dénonce le syndicat des revendeurs de
pièces détachées et en plus ces derniers
mois les prix se sont envolés
ça ça sert ni plus moins qu'à ouvrir la
porte sur une porte s appelle une
charnière de portières cette charnière
qui valait 37 euros 92 en janvier 2008
vos 107 euros 84 soit 184 % en
augmentation en septembre 2009 comme les
constructeurs automobiles français sont
les seuls à commercialiser ses produits
ils sont libres de fixer leurs prix et
voilà ça c'est le résultat d'un monopole
d'une absence totale de concurrence il y
avait de la concurrence sur ce marché
on serait comme sur le reste des pièces
plaquettes de frein embrayage etc
les différents acteurs économiques la
essaierait de placer leurs marchandises
à un coût compétitif et on aurait des
prix de marché qui serait tout à fait
compatible avec le pouvoir d'achat de
l'automobiliste actuellement nous avons
voulu connaître la position de ces
constructeurs
mais aucun d'entre eux n'a souhaité
s'exprimer officiellement il souhaite
protéger leurs créations et considère
que les pièces de carrosserie qui ne
sont pas d'origine serait dangereuse
une explication démentie par tous les
tests réalisés en laboratoire
résultat presque partout en europe le
marché de la carrosserie s'est ouvert à
la concurrence
sauf en france alors pour échapper aux
monopoles
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
contourner la loi est allé se fournir en
pièces détachées ailleurs et notamment
en belgique dans ce magasin spécialisé
on vend principalement de la copie de
pièce détachées 80% des clients sont
français
c'est vrai que c'est interdit de se
séparer de la contrefaçon c'est pas
c'est pas ce qui va amener je ne pense
pas la mort de quelqu'un ou certainement
pas la mienne je ne vois pas le rapport
entre du plastique et du plastique ça
reste du plastique tout simplement merci
bien vous laisse au revoir
le patron de cette société florissante
c'est eric il fait 4 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires par an deux fois par
semaine les pièces de carrosserie arrive
ici du monde entier des phares qui
vendent se pare chocs fabriqué en italie
par exemple est aux normes européennes
seules différences selon eric son prix
concessionnaires français 352 nous le
vendons et on gagne encore notre ville
on gagne bien notre vie nous le vendent
aux 38 euros 30
du coup la belgique est devenue la
plateforme de tous les trafics
pascal est venu exprès de paris
aujourd'hui parce qu'elle n'est pas un
particulier c'est un intermédiaire et ce
matin il est venu chercher une grosse
commande la de pare chocs
on a deux phares un radiateur pascal
fait le voyage pour des clients qui
n'ont pas le temps de venir en belgique
chercher leurs pièces détachées toutes
ses commandes se font par internet
il a monté son petit business il y à un
mois ya moyen de faire à 10 15 milles 10
15000 euros par mois au moins 10000 oui
en fait il n'a pas le droit de faire ce
qu'il fait il pourrait être poursuivi
pour concurrence abusive et déloyal par
les constructeurs français
c'est pour ça qu'il préfère être discret
sur la marchandise qu'ils transportent
car une fois la frontière passée
il devient contrefacteurs ce que ça
c'est tout le système qui est à remettre
en cause et amène à plat c'est légal en
allemagne c'est légal en hollande c'est
légal en belgique
pourquoi ça serait pas légale en france
parce qu'elle n'aura peut-être plus à se
cacher bien longtemps
l'année prochaine bruxelles pourrait
imposer à la france l'ouverture de son
marché à la concurrence